allora la relazione tra matematica e
contatto è una relazione multipla direi
che nasce molto anticamente nel senso
che nella geometria lo studio del
contatto tra le curve le superfici nasce
addirittura dell'antico egitto e
nell'antica grecia una una enorme
diffusione in cui la geometria veniva
considerata talmente la più alta delle
discipline delle matematiche
dopodiché ci sono altri ambiti sempre
classici per quelli di parole diciamo
che magari conoscono un po il termine di
fisica matematica cioè la matematica che
studia le equazioni della fisica i
modelli diciamo della realtà di tipo
fisico
esiste una matematica che studia i
problemi di contatto che sono problemi
molto difficili immaginate un biliardo
una palla che rotola su umiliano 2
interagisce con altre palle ci sono
matematici famosissimi che studiano
queste dinamiche molto complicate da qui
sono nati poi progetti interessantissimi
anche applicativi poi c'è una matematica
come dire anche nel contatto nella sua
accezione romantica nel contatto amoroso
e sorprendente ma c'è una matematica che
si occupa del contatto amoroso non solo
diciamo non pensate solo al al contatto
erotico alle leggi del moto in
quell'auto ombroso ma per esempio c'è un
articolo che mi sorprese molto qualche
anno fa e che mi colpì proprio per
caratteristiche che era un articolo
pubblicato sulla rivista internazionale
di valore che scriveva matematicamente
la dinamica del rapporto d'amore tra
petrarca e laura e questo diciamo è un
anno se siete curiosi scrivete il
miglior romanzo perché è una lettura
molto affascinante che poi ha
influenzato anche la letteratura cioè i
letterati che studiavano le fasi
letterarie di petrarca e dove terna in
relazione allo stato del suo rapporto
molto spirituale vero con laura ci
ricordiamo petrarca sognava via mare a
londra delle passioni quindi lontano
qualunque forma di erotismo era diciamo
ora assolutamente ideale quello di
petrarca per l'altro ecco invece la la
la cosa diciamo di cui parlerò oggi è
una matematica un po più recente moderna
che nasce intorno ai network in
particolare i social network particolare
a internet e che naturalmente pone delle
questioni che nella vita
c'erano c'erano neanche trenta anni fa
assolutamente nuove pratiche è molto
viva e un po quello che ci sorprende
meno sorprende me è che effettivamente
la matematica ha una capacità di
investigazione di conoscenza di
moderazione un po insospettate parlavo
ieri sera a cena chiedeva laura tra un
po di cosa parlerà il a matematica nel
contatto
lei giustamente diceva alla matematica
dappertutto e vero la matematica è
assolutamente dappertutto e nascosta
dappertutto
quando noi apriamo le nostre pagine sui
social
dietro ci sono algoritmi matematici che
lavorano che fanno un po in segreto
anche un po inquietante che anche
violano la nostra privacy che sanno i
nostri dati che ci propongono un fisico
molto famoso wiener parlava
dell'irragionevole efficacia della
matematica e lo diceva non solo con
ammirazione ma anche con un certo
disappunto e cioè dice la matematica
coraggiosamente si infila cerca di dare
un proprio contributo una sua
interpretazione alla formalizzazione di
cose apparentemente completamente
slegate una storia da un sito di dating
ed è efficace nel senso che poi da dei
risultati interessanti poi hanno un
risvolto importante socio economico
anche quindi rileva sono pietro
questioni molto importanti e quindi in
questo senso diciamo
interessante vederla all'opera in
settori dove in un certo qual modo uno
non sospetterebbe che che questo si
trovasse ecco che la matematica si trova
si cela un po misteriosamente dietro
settori allora quello che ti voglio fare
io raccontarvi la matematica del
contatto virtuale in sembra diciamo un
tema particolarmente moderno insomma
interessante da un punto di vista
proprio della situazione che stiamo
vivendo in cui il contatto virtuale ha
sostituito il contatto reale per molti
di noi in primis per me che ho figli e
lontane
allora la parola contatto è una parola è
un genere o nomato peikov il tocco no il
toccarsi un amato perico e viene dal
latino viene da con tingere è il
participio la parola con tinte e fa
pensare oltre questa sua questo suono fa
pensare qualcosa di molto realistico
concreto diciamo la parola virtuale è
assolutamente l'opposto ciò che è
impotenza ciò che non è reale che
potrebbe realizzare anche non è previsto
che si realizzi quindi in questo senso
al mio modo di opinione siamo quasi su
un ossimoro cioè sono due parole
fortemente antitetiche nella realtà
sentiamo parlare di contatto virtuale di
realtà virtuale quotidianamente quindi
diciamo forse poteva considerarsi un
ossimoro anni fa ma adesso è quasi più
concreto della realtà spesso per molti
di noi pericolosamente quindi intendere
contatto virtuale diventa un qualcosa un
oggetto interessante di studio alla
matematica non si è tirato indietro
bray vorrei sottolineare una cosa che la
matematica non appartiene a me non
appartiene ai matematici non ritengo che
abate che la grazia matematica e
dappertutto e appartiene a tutti tutti
quelli che ne fanno uso
tutti quelli che ne traggono
facciamo un vantaggio dal loro utilizzo
quindi non non ha assolutamente come
dire una connotazione di appartenenza
bene allora la matematica soprattutto la
matematica discreta queste queste branca
della matematica che sono molto studiato
ovviamente negli stati uniti in europa
in tutto il mondo permette che dovete
pensare che un social networ
informazione nostri per noi stessi è un
enorme masso di un enorme ammasso di
dati di relazioni eccetera
un po anche difficile da interpretare
quindi la matematica cerca di
razionalizzare cerca di di estrarre
delle informazioni e questo diciamo è
come dire l'esempio modello che io vi
porto oggi come direi una specie di
gioco allora pensiamo per esempio a
facebook dove il contatto la relazione
di amicizia cioè io e te siamo in
contatto è una cosa assolutamente di
direzionale molto diversa invece per
social network in cui c'è un follower
quindi una persona che segue una persona
che è seguita magari io seguo obama o il
presidente non sa chi sono io invece no
in su facebook è una relazione
bidirezionale
quindi diciamo risulta abbastanza
semplice individuare i leader facebook
no coloro che sono più rappresentativi
sono coloro che hanno più amicizie che
sono più sociali in questo senso il
numero dei contatti è un po un indice di
popolarità di successo sempre già così
si può interpretare allora come per
esempio in questo senso vedete che ci
sono due gruppi uno bianco e uno blu che
sono sostanzialmente due gruppi intorno
a un leader che concentrano la maggior
parte dei legami di amicizia e presente
potrebbe essere la suddivisione di un
insieme un sottoinsieme di facebook come
sappiamo fatto da miliardi di individui
per esempio sul fatto che ci sia
un'opinione quindi il gruppo blu ha
un'opinione
non è un'altra e poi ci sono vedete
anche due due individui che qui sono
semplicemente rappresentati attraverso
dei numeri che sono gialli e che
rappresentano dal punto di vista della
matematica
come dire individui di confine in cui la
classificazione più labile un po come
dire persone che stanno un po al confine
tra i due gruppi
quindi qui come dire l'individuazione di
due gruppi e jane per sé non volevano ma
un problema matematico non banale non
difficile ma non banale invece diciamo
l'individuazione dei leader se per
esempio voi contate i contatti risulta
essere estremamente semplici sono anche
occorre la matematica per contare il
numero dei dei contanti di amicizia più
interessante se volete è il caso di un
network come potrebbe essere twitter in
cui noi desideriamo individuare i
cosiddetti leader o i cosiddetti
influenza non so se voi avete letto su
giornali di ieri dell'altro ieri che i
candidati sindaci di roma si sono
affidati a degli influenze e parer faina
e mister marra per promuovere la loro
campagna elettorale quindi ha un impatto
sociale importante cioè non è solo un
gioco essere un leader essere un
influencer ha un impatto molto
importante come viene individuato allora
la matematica cosa fa maturare come
sempre no dicevo che facciamo un modello
astratto un formalizziamo facciamo dei
nodi questi pallini li numeri a amo
facciamo finta che siano in quattro in
questo network in questa retta di
matematici la chiamano grafo incolla
numero 1 laura numero 2 riccardo numero
3 e massimo numero 4 è bellissimo
facciamo questi quattro dopo di che
facciamo delle frecce non so se vedete
che qui ci sono delle frecce la freccia
di x sec si chiama arco e matematica in
teoria dei grafi è un segmento orientato
che va da un individuo all'altro
se c'è la freccia da tre a uno vuol dire
che tre segue 1 poi se la freccia e
bidirezionale vuol dire che tre segue 1
e 1 segue tre ma non è necessario vedete
per esempio che 2 segue 4 ma non
viceversa
allora la domanda che vi pongo sulla
quale vi invito a pensare fin da adesso
prima delle mie multa della mia della
fine della mia chiacchierata è questa
chi è secondo voi il leader il più
rappresentativo di questo napoli più
seguito allora ci sarebbe diciamo ci
sarebbe una risposta a mio parere molto
naturale la risposta che darei io se mi
fosse chiesto a mio parere
vediamo se anche la vostra guardatele un
attimo rifletteteci un attimo ci arrivò
subito io darei una risposta immediata
io direi subito che il 3 benissimo
indoviniamo lo supponiamo punto che
siano n individui maturati prende vuol
dire un certo numero n figli sono
quattro
avrei dovuto scrivere quattro sono
quattro individui abbiamo questo grafo
che vuol dire che l'individuo 1 segue
tre questo grado che ci rappresenta
quindi il contatto stabilito nel seguire
io seguo laura magari laurea nostri come
non sa neanche chi so e lo stesso
a questo punto io vorrei uscire da
questa ne ha matematicamente l'ora di
trovare il più rappresentativo quello
che magari a cui poi puoi riferirti come
dire come come leader di questa piccola
comunità è quello con il punteggio più
alto
cos'è un punteggio un punteggio numero
reale positivo dice matematico che ci
cerchiamo numero reale positivo da
associare a ognuno dei quattro individui
dei quattro notti come facciamo allora
il punteggio intanto madama le chiamiamo
loix chiamiamolo xk è questo è tipico il
tratto in un'aula di qualunque studio
che professori nave madre chiaro l'ex
bensì lo chiamiamo riscatto quindi
l'individuo 1 io ho un punteggio x1
individuerà un punteggio e quindi mi
aspetto questa associazione
ognuno esce da questa
da questa analisi con un numeretto e dal
confronto di questi numeretti si evince
qual è la sua importanza in questo
piccolo network
benissimo allora un esempio è il numero
di followers quanti mi seguono io più
importante sono quanti più followers
ovvio giusto però è un modello
imperfetto è un modello imperfetto che
da un certo punto di vista forse
condividerete con me che è imperfetto ma
adesso ne parliamo comunque uno seguendo
in fondo e spende che veramente il 3 e
quello che è seguito da tutti e quindi
il più rappresentativo non seguono tutti
qual è il difetto
il fatto è che se mi seguono tra i miei
compagni di classe
forse mi seguono il presidente degli
stati uniti
il presidente il presidente della russia
e il primo ministro inglese è diverso
anche perché attraverso di loro tutti
coloro che seguono loro molto
rapidamente arrivano a mente che abbiano
la guerra presidente stati uniti
inverosimile benissimo quindi questo è
un primo punto allora chi si fa qual è
il modello più evoluto e qui entra una
tematica sennò prima su contare ce la
caviamo tutti
calcoliamo il punteggio come somma dei
punteggi che ci segue quindi se mi segue
una persona più importante io non conto
uno che li segue conto quanto vale lui
qual è il suo punteggio
lo riporta non è un mio compagno di
classe che magari non conta conta i
danni da poco diciamo contribuisce il
pop al mio punteggio è invece una
persona magari appunto di grande non è
la rilevanza conta di più e quindi il
mio punteggio non è più nessuno non è
più 2 legato al fatto che 34 lo seguono
ma ex1 lewis 4
questa però adesso ci con un problema
che non è più una relazione scritta è
una reazione implicita perché a loro
volta e stress 4 dipendo da nessuno
allora se voi vi ricordate ai tempi del
liceo della scuola superiore sparava di
sistemi di equazioni
si parlava del metodo di eliminazione di
caos laura tutti lo ricordi perché lì
bravissima tematiche benissimo promette
queste quattro equazioni applica il
metodo di eliminazione di casa e risolve
il problema e dai quattro punteggi se un
altro piccolo difetto
e con questo concludo il fatto è che se
io decido di puntare tutti di seguire
tutti o molto più influenza di uno che
invece più invece più moderato segue
veramente che gli interessa basta quindi
pone un diverso effetto sul network
tra me e lei tramello io seguo tutti
l'altro la segue due quindi olio molto
più impatto allora che si fa
se io seguo tre persone
l'effetto del mio seguire queste tre
persone viene diviso per tre
il mio voto viene diviso per tre io so
un voto solo quindi secondo mille
persone questi mille e c'erano un
millesimo del mio punteggio
questa è l'idea di democrazia e la
burocrazia importanti
alla fine quindi vedete che se torniamo
un attimo indietro
vedete che uno è seguito da tre e da
quattro ma tre segue solo 1 mentre
quattro segue 1 ma anche tre quindi
questo mi dice che il punteggio x1
spero che vi stiate perdendo è il
punteggio di x3 dell'effetto di x3 che è
molto fedele ex una punta solo lui segue
solo lui io ho un solo sono follower di
una persona sola
extreme quindi partecipa con tutto il
proprio voto mentre il 4 individuo 4
massimo non solo segue segue un'altra
persona quindi il suo punteggio viene
diviso tra noi due
e questo è un principio di equità di
democrazia nella matematica è un
principio di equilibrio
ok quindi a quel punto noi otteniamo un
sistema lineare leggermente diverso la
pregiudiziale
quello che non terrebbe conto di questa
di questa mediazione e otteniamo una
cosa interessante che i leader non è il
il leader è l'uno in un certo senso ma
adesso non voglio qui questo ce lo dice
la matematica e questo è quello che la
matematica basso il network cioè quello
che poi viene utilizzato comunemente in
tutti gli algoritmi tutte le metodologie
matematiche che vengono utilizzate per
esplorare ned social network internet e
per dare informazioni anche
pubblicitarie quindi siamo con forte
impatto sul sicuro
diciamo che l'unica cosa che vi posso
dire che uno è il più importante perché
in fondo 3 seguito da tutti ma in questo
modo è seguito anche dal più debole
quindi come dire se posso dare una
umanità trazione un po grossolana meglio
non essere seguiti in questi termini da
un fondo per molto debole che abbassa il
nostro punteggio con questo ci amano
qualsiasi altro mio appunto come di una
mia opinione commento quello che fa la
grita una tematica e e questo è quello
che io volevo raccontarvi con questo
concludo semplicemente con un ultimo
accenno a una cosa interessante della
matematica di cui oggi non vi parlo che
è quella che la matematica oltre questo
non solo analizza i contatti quindi i
contatti sono loro che la che
l'algoritmo nella ricerca ma costruisce
contatti dove non ci sono
uno in un sito di dating si trova la
mattina dieci candidati a essere propria
anima gemella che alcol nati con metodi
matematici statistici di affinità di
gusto eccetera netflix stabilisce gusti
simili tra persone diverse per farli
delle pubblicità attraverso magari
connessioni con amici comuni ma i due
non si conoscono quindi la matematica
anche in grado di creare contatto e non
solo di analizzarlo e quindi di influire
pesantemente sulla realtà crea dei
contatti crea delle relazioni però non
abbiate paura è uno strumento
vi ringrazio montesi
[Applauso]